I'm chip Conley I'm the founder of Xuan
Aviv which became the second largest
boutique hotel company in the United
States I graduated from Stanford
Business School when I was 23 I went to
work for a commercial real estate
developer who had gone to Stanford
Business School ten years before me but
I was bored and I decided I want to do
something those more creative 2530 years
ago business people were guys in suits
and they just sort of implemented
bigness and they didn't have creative
ideas they weren't rebellious in their
thinking so I decided to create a
boutique Motel in the Tenderloin of San
Francisco place called the Phoenix where
we're sitting right now it's in a bad
neighborhood but what we did is we
created a concept for the hotel
something that felt adventurous and had
sort of an artistic spirit about it I
like to call it the crossroads for
creative people every time we create a
hotel it's based upon a magazine and the
first one was based upon rolling stone
we came up with five adjectives that
defined Rolling Stone because magazines
and boutique hotels have something in
common their niche branded and lifestyle
oriented so this first hotel was based
upon rolling stone which we thought was
funky irreverent adventurous cool and
young at heart and frankly what we
learned is that the people who fell in
love with the hotel would use those five
adjectives to describe themselves within
a year it became a very famous
rock-and-roll hotel some of the bands
who've stayed here at the Phoenix
include David Bowie Pearl Jam Red Hot
Chili Peppers Nirvana so it's definitely
a hangout a place where people would
come and know that in San Francisco this
is through an artistic Oasis that's
funky but has a soul
my belief in creating joie de vivre on
the front end was let's keep our hotels
affordable over time what we did is we
focused on boutique hotels from low end
to high end from the Phoenix or the tomo
a japanese-inspired hotel in Japan town
in San Francisco to the vitaliy a very
high-end Hotel in the financial district
over the course of the quarter century
we created 52 boutique hotels yeah they
went swimming oh yeah I think CEOs are
chief emotions officers because I think
more than anything what we need to
understand as leaders is how do we
motivate our people and how do we
satisfy our guests and behind both of
those is understanding their needs so
the way you create meaning for someone
who's made in a hotel or cooking a
kitchen you help them to see that the
work that they're doing is having an
impact on the customer so what that
means is you need to have customers come
in and talk to your staff very few
companies do this what we've done over
the course of a long period of time is
just make sure that we're broadcasting
stories from guests sometimes it's in an
email
sometimes it's face to face at a staff
meeting so that our employees can
actually hear the impact of their work
the best thing you can do is to label
your emotions label your emotions
understand where you are because it
takes you to a different place in your
brain what I learned along the way is
that understanding people and
understanding myself is probably the
most important gift I learned from
Business School and then it's probably
the most important thing I learned along
the way thank you very much